翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
ゆっくり目を閉じてください
空をふわりと浮かんでいるところを
イメージしてください
特に足を使っているわけでもなく
手を使ってるわけでもありません
ただ頭で思い描いた通り
自由に空を飛んでいるところを
考えてください
ゆっくり目を開けてください
私はこんな世界が造りたいと思っています
脳波が導く
新しい挑戦をしたいと思っています
私たちは日々
考えたり感じたり
想像したりしています
そして
そういった思考や感情っていうのは
この身体のどこから
生まれてきているのかっていうのは
非常に多くの研究者が
昔から考えてきました
一方私は 情報工学という分野で
人工知能をはじめとして
自律型ロボットの研究
またロボットの目となる
画像認識の研究 そして
人とロボットのコミュニケーションに
関する研究を行ってきました
そういう研究を行いながら
頭のなかで
何とかして 人の意図通りに
動くようなロボットを造れないか？
とても簡単なんですね
目的は簡単なんですが
とても難しいテーマを持っていました
まず 最初の映像を見て頂きたいと思います
これは2011年
約５年前にうちの研究室で造った
ロボットになります
既存の車いすを改造して造りました
これは
いくつかのセンサーを使って
壁までの距離を見ながら
自分の位置を把握しながら
目的地を入れられたらその場所に
GPSなしで 室内で
思いどおりのところに
行くようなロボットを造りました
それだけではなくて当然
壁にぶつかりそうになったりだとか
ドアがあったらそれを避けるような
ものを作ってます
それ以外にも
音声を認識して
反応するロボットだとか
人の後ろについていくような
フォローイングするような
ロボットを造ってました
まあこういうロボットを考えながらも
私の頭の中では
やっぱり人の感情だとか
思考っていうのは
一体どこから来ているのかということを
考えていました
たまたまなんですが
私の息子の
脳波を採る機会を得ました
そして何度も
その脳波を観たりだとか
担当のお医者さんと相談しながら
この脳波はどうなってるんですか
ということを何度も相談しました
そういう相談を重ねていくうちに
徐々に脳波って
あぁこんなことが分かるんだというのが
理解できるようになったんですね
それと同時に
もともと脳波っていうのは
医療界だけだったんですが
医療界以外でも使える脳波の読み取り装置が
できあがってくるようになりました
脳っていうのは
非常に柔らかい器官でできてまして
頭皮と頭蓋の中で 脳は安定した形で
浮いてる形で位置しています
そして人の活動にともなって
その脳内に微量な電位が流れて
それが頭皮に対して電位として現れます
その電位を集計したものが
脳波という形になります
この脳波で人の活動がわかる
もしくは人の思っていることがわかる
というのが徐々に分かってきた
ということです
実際 これは私の脳波です
まず私がですね
画面上で 右下に
数字が２と出ますけれども
数字を観ているだけの状態の時の
脳波の映像を撮っています
５秒間 ブランクの画像があった時に
15秒間ランダムで数字を出してます
ランダムにする意味っていうのは
人って何もない時に
次の数字を想像しちゃうんですね
なのでそれを防ぐために
ランダムに数字を出してます
ランダムで出てきた数字の時に
たとえば今３という数字が出てますが
一番上の —
今消えてますね
次に出てくるのを待ちましょうか
１という数字が出てきた瞬間に
ちょっと一番上の波形が
上がったり下がったりしますよね
これが
人が非常に意識をしている
もしくは何かを見つけたときに出てくる
P300という特定の周波数です
それと同時に 一番下の波形のところも
実を言うと 何か形が変わっています
これは 一般的に視野角と言われる
人が見たものを
イメージする脳波になっていまして
これを採ることによって
何か人が感じている 見ているものが
理解できるんじゃないかと思っています
私はこう言っているとよく
脳科学者と間違われるんですが
全く脳科学者じゃありません
一般の情報工学の大学の教員です
なんですが たぶんこれを見ただけでも
なにかこの見ているものと
出てくる脳波には関連性がある
ということに気づいたわけです
脳波っていうのはですね
実を言うといろんな情報が入っています
人の五感
嗅覚をはじめ視覚だとか
いろんなものが入ってきたりだとか
あとは ―
筋電
いわゆる筋肉の情報も
この脳波にのってきます
そのために私の専門分野ではあるんですが
情報工学の力を借りて
情報のフィルタリングだとか
ディープラーニングを始めとする
機械学習を使ってます
機械学習の意味なんですが
例えば皆さん
私持ってるんですが
iPhoneとかAndroidもあるんですが
iPhoneの場合はSiriで
音声認識をやったりだとか
Facebookをやっていると
顔の認識をしてくれます
まあそれはひとつの機械学習なんですが
世の中にある大量のデータ
ビッグデータと呼ばれる
大量のデータを集めてきて
それを計算機に入れて
学習することによって自動的に計算機は
規則を作ってくれるんですね
で 新しいデータが入ってきたら
その前の規則にどれが一番近いのか
ということをやってくれるのが
ディープラーニングの世界です
私はこのディープラーニングの研究を
これまでやってきましたし
これからも続けていこうと思ってます
それは脳波に対して こういう
ディープラーニングを用いることによって
何か生活の助けになるんじゃないか
ということを思ってます
その中でまず１つ目に造ったのが
ここに示すような
ブレインウェーブズと
ディープラーニングを重ねて
ロボティックスハンドを作りました
これはこの若者が —
この研究室の若者なんですが
開け閉じろっていうことを
今使っているのは脳波だけです
脳波だけを使ってそれを操作してます
今開きましたよね
この後閉じる
強く思うと
ちょっと時間はかかるんですが
閉じてくれたりします
ゆっくりですね
まあこれが最初造ってですね
いくつかのメディアに取り上げられて
一時期注目を浴びました
当然 いくつかの企業からも
やはりお誘いがかかって
商談というかですね
こういう共同研究をやりませんか
ということをいきましたが
まぁだいたいことごとく
断られてしまいました
これはすぐにビジネスに
繋がるものじゃないのかっていう視点が
やはり企業の方は多かった気がします
まぁなかなかそこまで行きつかなかったのが
正直なところです
そこで次にうちの研究室としてはですね
これをじゃあ元々やっていた
車いすに適用してみようということで
彼のように脳波を読み取る機械を頭につけて
前、右、左、止まれ
ということを脳波で
コントロールしていました
何となく動いていますよね
でもこれ最大の欠点があります
ずっと考えていないといけない
（笑）
「右行け」って言ってて
一瞬のうちに「左」って思ったら
違うところへ行っちゃったりとか
一番いやなのが
「壁にぶつかるな～！」と思っても
脳波を読みとるのに
若干２秒かかるんです
ぶつかっちゃうんですね
そういう点では
これは研究室の中で使えます
ただやっぱり
実用的に使えるかどうかって言ったら
やはり疑問点があったかと思います
で 私たちは考えました
もうちょっと賢く
車いすを自動制御できるものは
ないかということを考えました
そしてちょうど１年ほど前ですね
新しい車いすを作りました
この時もまた脳波で考えてますが
ほんの２秒ほど考えたら
目的地を指定させるようにしました
そうすると目的地までは
あとは車が自動的に 自律的に
その場所まで連れて行ってくれます
車いすの上にはセンサーがついていて
壁までの距離を測りながら
自分の位置を確実に測定してます
なので乗ってる人は
最初「どこに行きたいか」って
いうことを考えれば
あとは何も考える必要はありません
当然危ないものだったりとか
ちょっと意地悪なこういう人が来ても
ちゃんとエマージェンシーストップ
という形で止まってくれます
こういう風なシステムを
作っていきました
これはこれで
結構取り上げられたんですが
まだまだこの研究には
続きがあると思っています
この自律走行 —
脳波を使って 目的地を指定させ
自律走行させるっていうのは
ある意味画期的だったんですが
実際私も乗ってみました
若干気持ち悪いんですよね
（笑）
なぜかというと
思ってその場所に行くのはいいんですが
例えばいろんな人が —
ここで大事な話をしますが
色んな人が歩いてる
もしくはものが横にあったりだとかして
ちょっと見たい —
人が来たからちょっとお話をしてみたい
といっても
前の自律走行だったら
自動的に行っちゃうんですね
たぶんこれは 今Googleだとか
いくつかの自動車メーカーが作っている
自律走行車も同じことだと思います
たぶんその場所行っちゃうんですね
思った通りに動かない —
思った通りに動いてるんですよ
（笑）
ですけど
ちょっと立ち寄ってみたりだとか
今ここに出て来ているように
ちょっとこの彼としゃべってみたい
と思った時には
自律走行車だけではできません
脳波っていうのは
思考したものを導く以外に
脳波の中に出ているのは
さきほどちょっと言ったんですが
五感だとか視線だとか筋電も
入ってきてます
前は捨ててた情報だったんですが
今はこれを利用しています
ただ まだ完成はしてません
というか 初めてこれ
一般に公開している状態なので
初ものです
（笑）
私は こういう形で
いろんな脳波を使った
プロダクトをやっていますが
おかげさまで
いろいろなメディアに取り上げられ
多くの方と知り合うことができました
例えば医療従事者
あとは実際にALS患者さんだとか
脳はしっかりしているんですけど
身体が動かない患者さんに
いろいろ出会うことがありました
またその家族だとかその介護者と
出会うことがありました
いろんなことをたぶん切望され
要望も聞いたりだとか
いろいろな理解を
私も求めたことがあります
おかげさまでいろんな方と
知り合うことができましたし
こういう車いすの研究があるということも
理解してもらえたという点があります
そして私は
もっとこの車椅子だとか
自律走行車でもいいんですが
誰もが使いたいと思うような移動支援
まだ車いすは
生活シーンには使えないんですね
これを何とか使えるようにしていきたい
と思ってます
そういう点では私は
いろんな方に対して
いろんな多様な人が
分け隔てなく暮らせる社会を
何かの形でサポートしていきたいと
思ってます
私にできることは
ほんの小さなことだと思いますが
やっぱり私は実現したいんですね
手足がなくても頭で考えれば
思った場所 思った行動が
できるようになりたい
そういう研究を
今後も続けていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）